let f of t equal e to the 2t minus 2t
squared and H of T equal 4 minus 5t
squared the graphs of y equals f of T
and y equals H of T are shown below so y
equals f of T is here in green so this
is really y is equal to e to the 2t
minus 2t squared and we see f of T right
over there and Y is equal H of T is
shown in yellow all right now below that
they say which of the following appear
to be solutions of e to the 2t minus 2t
squared equals 4 minus 5t squared select
all that apply and I encourage you to
pause the video and try to think about
it now the key here is to realize that e
to the 2t minus 2t squared that was F of
T and thought four minus 5t squared is H
of T so another way of thinking about it
select all of the all of the T's for
which f of T for which F of T is equal
to H of T so all of the T's where F of T
is equal to H of T well that's going to
happen at the points of intersection so
for example at t1 we see at this point
right here t1 y1 so this tells us F of T
1 is equal to H of T 1 which is equal to
y1 so f of T is going to be equal to H
of T at T is equal to t1 now we see that
there cuz it's a point of intersection
now let's keep on going well they have
another point of intersection right over
here at T for T the cot of T 4 y 4 if
you took F of T 4 you're going to get Y
4 or if you take H of T 4 you're going
to get Y 4 so f of T 4 is equal to H of
T 4 F of T 4 is equal to H of T 4 so if
you took eetu the two times T sub 4
minus 2 T sub 4 squared and all the way
that's going to be equal to 4 minus 5
times T sub 4 squared so T sub 4 since
it satisfies both F
since F of T and H of T equal each other
when T is equal to T sub for these two
things are going to equal each other
when T is equal to T sub before and
those are the only ones that are at a
point of that are at a point of
intersection and so I think we I think
we are not I can check my answer and got
it right